in this video i'm going to tell you
exactly how you can make 5 000 pounds a
month profit clean profit from a
strategy called deal sourcing packaging
and selling property investments to
other people let me tell you something i
am a multi-millionaire right now and i'm
living i live in a nice big house i'm
standing right now in my garden okay and
i became a millionaire not from
investing in property i didn't become
millionaire from property investing i
didn't become a millionaire from having
a training company or from forex i
became a millionaire from finding
properties and passing them on to other
people for a fee and it's really
difficult for me to feel sorry for
people when they when they tell me how
broke they are like if someone says to
me oh man i'm so broke i've not got
enough money to invest everything's
going up in value apart from wages i'm
struggling to pay my bills i can't feel
sorry for them
because i know that they could just do
this what i'm going to tell you right
now in this video there were times when
i was like a teenager when i was 18 19
years old i was so skint i had nothing i
had no money i remember when i was dr i
was i was driving around a ford focus ka
it was purple because it was the cheaper
color so i'm driving a purple
ka and my petrol is so low but i know i
haven't got any money so i can't i can't
top it up my car breaks down i'm pushing
my car to a petrol station when i get
there i've got zero money my cards are
all being declined i'm skint i'm having
to ring my little sister who's at school
and ask her to borrow five pounds to
just about get home like i know what
it's like to be skinned now my net worth
is 20 million pounds and i i got to
where i am from this strategy so let me
explain what it is let me tell you
exactly how you can do it too okay no
matter how inexperienced you are no
matter how lack of money you've got
right now this can replace any job even
if you're a doctor or a dentist or a
freaking brain surgeon brain surgeons
are broke compared to people that do
this okay
and that's this property investing
buying houses and renting them out is
one of the most lucrative ways to make
money on the planet if you look on the
sunday times rich list all the
successful business owners the people
that are making hundreds of millions of
pounds they're investing in property
lloyd's bank are investing in property
buying properties is for the rich it's
what the rich people do now
buying properties is also a bit of a
nightmare
right now the market's booming if you
want to find a good deal right now
you've got to go out you've got to call
agents you've got to go and view
properties and on a tuesday afternoon on
the rain just to get gazumped it takes a
lot of time and a lot of energy so
what's deal sourcing deal sourcing is
quite simply finding
properties negotiating with agents
viewing properties
are offering low prices getting good
deals which takes time and work and
sweat and determination and courage
but then when you get an offer accepted
and it's a good deal rather than buying
it because you've got no money
you pass it to an investor you pass it
to somebody who's busy you pass it to
somebody who's got money in the bank but
hasn't got much time and they pay you on
average a two
percent finders fee
they pay you two percent for finding the
deal now you might think
who are these people why would they pay
two percent why would they pay me why
would they pay me i'll tell you i'll
tell you right imagine you find a house
that's worth a million pounds
but you negotiate to buy it for nine
hundred thousand
that's a hundred thousand pounds below
market value
if you found that deal today would
somebody pay you
twenty thousand pounds two percent
finders fee for that deal and the answer
is yes how do i know that because i do
all the time in fact recently i just
paid somebody twenty thousand pounds
cash bang because they found me a deal
it was a million pound property
investment
so if you wanna make money in property
and you've got no money you want to make
five thousand pounds clean profit a
month then the key is rather than
working really hard on your job and
trying to save up money and by the time
you've saved for a deposit after 10 20
years properties have doubled in value
anyway you still ain't got enough if
you're struggling to keep up with the
cost of inflation and working hard like
a slave on a job then simply become a
property deal sorcerer now
some issues that you might be thinking
right now might be thinking about saying
i don't know any investors maybe
thinking i don't know how to find a good
deal maybe thinking what about the
compliance and the contracts i don't
understand that stuff let me tell you
something right
let me tell you right now i don't think
i've ever shared this on youtube before
but many of my students are doing this
and i'm making 5 000 pounds as a minimum
in profit
let's say you've got no investors you
don't know anybody
let's say you don't have a company
let's say your company you haven't got
any compliance any contracts any
experience and you think this is not
possible for you
let me tell you how you can do this
without investors you don't need one
investor to make money in the exact same
way no contracts no compliance no
nothing here's what you do
you find somebody
who's already doing it
you find a deal sourcer
that's already got investors
they've already got the contracts and
the compliance and the insurances
they're already selling deals and
believe me there's thousands of people
like this in the uk
you find them where do you find them you
find them online you find them on social
media you find them on instagram maybe
you just find them at a networking event
come down to a property seminar okay and
you say to them
what are your investors looking for
right now
what are your investors looking for now
let's say they say oh my investors are
looking for
um
million pound mansions in birmingham
that are 20 below market value
you go okay cool all they say i'm
looking my investors are all looking for
hmo properties that will make a 20
return on investment
you say okay cool
if i
can do all the work
and can find a deal like that that your
investor would want
and i give you that deal and i pass that
opportunity onto you
would you be willing to split
the two percent finders fee with me 50
50. so from the deal sources perspective
they're doing nothing all they're doing
is utilizing their list of investors
their experience their contracts their
compliance that's it
you are doing all of the
elbow grease all of the work you're
finding the deal that's
i mean if the average property in the in
the uk is about 300 000 pounds that's
six thousand pounds for an average
finder's fee
you're not going to get the whole 6 000
you're just making about 3 thousand
pounds but you didn't even need a
business
you started with nothing you didn't need
an investor list you didn't need
compliance and insurance
that's how you make three thousand
pounds you do that twice a month
that's six thousand pounds a month
after three months then you set up your
own business then you start doing it
through your own investors list having a
job is not a necessity being poor is not
an excuse having no money does not mean
that you cannot make money in property
this is something that anyone can do i
did this with no gcse good grades or
results failed miserably in school i did
this from a standing start made a
million pounds cash and then invested
that myself into property and that's
that's how i'm here that's why i'm where
i am right now so the question is what's
your excuse you can either right now do
one of two things you can either try and
find more excuses oh but um
i i think i've robbed you of pretty much
every excuse i can think of but you can
try and find an excuse or you can say
you know what i'm going to do this let's
go and if you're going to do this and
you want to go i want to be acquainted
with you add me on instagram tell me
your intentions let me hold you to
account come join me come down to a live
training program again i i run a
training program called the property
investors crash course where i teach
people exactly this
how to find deals how to sell them
people go but i can't afford your
courses they're too expensive i'll get
rid of your excuse again the course
costs one pound
how much more could i could i get could
i could i eliminate people's excuses
i'll leave a link below if you want to
get booked on it's a one pound
fade to come down to the property
investors crash course so guys while
we're doing this video i'm doing this
video because i'm tired of people being
broke complaining thinking that there's
no way to get out most rich people hide
away and don't share like how i share
openly i want to see you win i want to
be part of your story i want to
interview you on my youtube channel and
you can tell me how you absolutely
killed it in property as a result of my
videos and my support so i'll see you at
the program i look forward to seeing you
win doing deal sourcing and i am over
and out god bless
[Music]